Samantha is in Indiana hi Samantha
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi guys
thank you so much for taking this call
sure what's up my question is this my
husband and I are on baby set to you and
I remaining that is just once combined
we are $117,000 recently we've had two
different family members offer to help
us pay down this debt and I don't know
if it my pride getting in the way of
wanting to accept their generosity but I
feel like it's our mess and it's our
responsibility to clean it up on our own
and my husband feels a little
differently son seeking your advice okay
are there any other issues like you
would be judged or they would interfere
in your life or there's toxicity
attached to the gift not at all no we
are very blessed with our family and
they're coming from a place of love and
they have they have the money it doesn't
leave them in any damage right my
husband's grandmother is the one person
who is offering to pay a substantial
amount upside like a son and my mother
is offering to help make payment now I
know my mother while she has a very high
income I know she has debts of her own
and I want to see her complete her
financial plan and it feels almost
selfish to take money when I know that
she's got a few liters dr. Farhat yes
she needs to clean up her mess she
doesn't need to be giving you money I
agree yeah and Samantha how did you how
did you say your husband feels about
this and he was very excited when his
grandmother offered to pay quite a nice
sum of money what's the day when she was
talking about um she will pay off his
balance and insisted 17,000 so she would
wipe his away when I mentioned that my
mom would be offering to help I mean he
was like open like that's great that'll
help us not to set down you know because
our plans are to go forward and take
down this bed and get us our first home
and
and progress you know so he's he's on
board but I feel like I've made such a
huge mess and I've been complimented by
my family and on how much maturity I
gained through the program financially
and I feel like by accepting money it'll
like take some of that no I think if the
people were if the people are in
condition to give the money without if
they're in the right place now your
mother is not she does not need to be
giving you money okay
she has an income but she's broke mm-hmm
so she doesn't need to be giving you
money so so the people are in a good
place and there's no toxicity meaning
they're not going to come over and say
and feel like they can tell you how to
what color to paint your bedroom after
they gave you some money or something
you know there's no control issues
attached to the money and I'm sure with
grandmother there's not so grandmother's
offering $17,000 as a gift do we have
any idea how much money grandmother
might have a million ten million or
eighteen thousand oh it's so hard to say
but my husband is kind of indicated that
he thinks that she is a millionaire okay
so 17,000 17,000 is no stretch yeah if
we're not leaving her in her harmed and
she's not gonna interfere then I think
it's a wonderful gift from her and I
would accept that gift and say thank you
okay thank you I would not accept it
from your mom because your mom's broke
yeah that's right
and Dave you're absolutely right about
the toxic thing because see if someone's
given you something it's got some
strings attached to it that's not a gift
that's called a loan because at some
point there's a whole long that's gonna
lure attached to efficiency exactly
right they're gonna pull it back and so
what the spirit needs to be the right
way and and they I agree with that I
think that's so important because what
you don't want to do is block someone's
blessing if they're trying to be kind
and generous to you now if they tell you
on the front end here's the terms of the
gift and that's all there is it's not
it's not gonna be ongoing then you can
you can accept those terms
right then that's okay you know and so
if it's something weird you would say no
but you know for instance I know I got a
friend of mine gave his kids enough to
pay off their home under the condition
they promise to never borrow again now
that's a good absolutely yeah but he
doesn't go over there and go now let me
see your wallet let's see if you got a
credit card right he didn't do that but
they know and they're honourable his
kids are that they're not gonna drive up
in a car with a car payment after he
gave him the money pay off the house
right because that was the condition of
the gift because he's trying to break
the chain on his family tree trying to
say no more it ends here and that so
that's a conditional gift that isn't
toxic yeah absolutely
if he's gonna give him money and go we
just name your first kid after me that's
toxic yeah
probably a great yeah but it's also
doctor yeah you can't buy that well
what's funny is I worked with a lady
years ago her and her husband had built
a net worth of three to five million and
one of the conditions in the trust so
that her three sons have to go through
Financial Peace University yeah every
other year well if not they forfeit the
money that year to a charity whoa and it
is in stone she goes they're not gonna
fritter this away she goes we work too
hard yeah and her spirit was right yeah
in the midst of that that might be a
little much well every other year for
the rest of their life every other year
for the first five years oh oh yeah so
three times and it okay that's fine
that's not as bad I have heard people
put in financial University in the will
I have heard that yeah oh yeah but I I'm
more concerned with you know then
they're gonna question you once you're
debt-free and you're handling money
right you you you went on a cruise you
went on vacation you know and they just
start they get the money gives them
permission to constantly interfere and
as our friend dr. John Looney says or my
friend dr. Henry cloud says violate
boundaries yeah you know they're gonna
come in and just walk around in your
living room metaphorically in their
muddy boots you know and tell you how to
do everything from then on you can't
accept that that's not a gift that's
just a control free it is and so you
just have to gauge that out
then you look and say you know can mama
afford discs and congrats you'd be I
mean the number of calls I've taken over
the years where the grandparents were
buying stuff for the grandkids and they
were in debt yes and couldn't afford it
I've taken that call on the show here
hundreds and hundreds of times and the
you know the mom and dad are like 35 or
30 or whatever they're going my parents
are broke and yet they keep spending all
this money that they don't have yep on
the grandkids and it's like well
grandkids are excused to be stupid I
mean but that's really and it's they
said it's just offensive and I don't
know how to stop it and that's somebody
who's again it's a toxic situation where
you know folks are not living within
their means and it's not a blessing but
if you've built up money and you've
changed your family tree and you know
you're like granny they're your everyday
millionaire and you want to reach over
and help your grandson have 17,000
that's a wonderful thing it is it's a
wonderful thing that really and truly is